[Music]
divinity original sin was one of my
favorite games when it launched on PC
back in 2014
beyond renting divinity - from the local
choices for a weekend back in 2009 I had
never had much experience in Larian
Studios dense universe but with original
sin I was immediately thrown into this
new world intrigued by the law and the
characters and enraptured by the depth
of its mechanics to me at least the game
seemed to come out of nowhere it was a
new release in the midst of a steam
summer sale while it could have been
easily lost in the swell of discounts
instead all my focus was redirected into
trying to have a meaningful conversation
with an exploding sheep admittedly I
felt out of my depth and lost in all the
mechanics and possibilities of the game
yet these were the exact reasons why
divinity original sin managed to sink
its claws into me with a grip that
showed no sign of loosening the more I
played the more I fell in love with
divinity although as a consumer as
someone who was just experiencing the
end result of a developer's hard work I
had no idea the chances that Larian had
to take to make this game a reality and
how many times they came close to
falling
[Music]
[Applause]
larrya was founded in 1996 and
immediately started work on a title
called Ragnarok unless an RPG that they
managed to sell to Atari during the same
time they were pushing the Jaguar
console and making moves into the PC
space although when Atari moved away
from games adjustments had to be made
and Ragnarok became the lady the mage
and the Knights the game that Larian
would tried to sell to publishers around
the world the game that they hoped would
make a name for themselves unfortunately
things didn't exactly go smoothly German
publisher attic Entertainment signed on
with a view to fund and published a
project which saw Larian expand from a
small three monte m-- to an office of
around 30 people but while development
was well underway attic entertainment
visited III and got to feast their eyes
on a little game called Diablo 2 now
Diablo 2 was 16-bit the lady the major
the night was a bit that was simply not
enough bits to compete my dudes so we
need to make it 16-bit which basically
meant redoing everything so they said no
problem we're gonna send you a bunch of
German developers to help you and we're
going to get you a license in the dark
eye which was this really popular German
RPG universe similar to Dungeons &
Dragons like the German version of
Dungeons & Dragons which meant that we
had to really everything everything and
so we started doing that but
unfortunately their games didn't sell as
well as they wanted so they ran out of
money so they couldn't pay any more and
suddenly we found ourselves not only
with our own team but also now with the
German team that we had to pay for and
we need to figure out something and so
we started doing work for hire and as we
did that we started making divinity and
this is how the first divinity came to
be during all the stress of doing their
work for hire projects and the mental
tax of bankruptcy being a very real
thing the team continued to chip away at
their passion project the very first
divinity game which was eventually
released in August of 2002 it was
originally going to be called divinity
the sword of lies which Swain admits
wasn't the best title but when CDV
software picked them up and had a huge
success with sudden strike they decided
that all their game titles needs at have
alliteration
unless the name divine divinity was born
however that isn't to say the launch
went off without any hitches so divinity
launched in difficult circumstances
wasn't finished when it released and
which became a team throughout the
history of the studio unfortunately and
but it did get quite a bunch of
followers so it got quite a lot of
critical acclaim once we started rolling
out the patches and a troop there was a
there was a market for this in an
interview with PC gamer so when admitted
that even he didn't know the game had
launched as he found out midway through
the press tour oh and also admitting to
the tiny fact that the game had launched
with a whopping 7,000 bugs obviously
most of the reviews focused on some of
the bigger flaws but as those were
ironed out players were drawn to divine
divinities ideas and saw the game in a
new light despite it selling well and
gaining acclaim as time went on Larian
was once again struggling for cash the
contract under which they made divinity
limited the amount of royalties the
studio would receive and because of that
the studio was hemorrhaging funds
resulting in the team going from 30
people back down to 3 just five months
after divinity had launched
understandably with a blow like that
anyone would need time to reflect
swen took a fortnight in South Africa to
reflect on what would come next for
Larian after convincing a bank to float
them small capital and talking a Belgian
broadcast network in to take Lehren on
for more work-for-hire projects Larian
survived but wasn't out of the fire just
yet this move did however give allowing
the opportunity to work on beyond
divinity and expand the team to around
25 people the growth allowed Larian to
keep afloat for some time until it
gathered the capital resources and
talent to make a full divinity sequel
divinity to ego Draconis now this was a
big step for the series as the studio
secured a license to use the elder
scrolls Oblivion's gamebryo engine and
this allowed them to release their first
console game but even with the new sense
of for mental and of them Larian and
their games were still facing pitfalls
as we progress we ran into the classical
problems so we started making cuts
started making adaption adaptations of
the game but the fundamentals of it
remained solid and so suddenly there was
much more pressure than we expected to
release and we weren't ready the release
happened because there was no more
finance game was not ready yet and so
that cost an enormous amount of stress
because everybody was unhappy about the
fact that it was releasing whereas it
really needed another year
cooker and the proof of that is that we
didn't go to rights back who made the
Dragon Knight saga which was a like
finishing actually where they go there
Kunis was in the Metacritic wind up with
10% so now imagine if that would have
been the thing that wouldn't release
originally that game would have been a
big hit I'm pretty sure of that in order
to regain control of the future of their
games and how they were managed Larry
and pursued independence which allowed
them to decide what went in their games
when they were ready and when they would
be released after scraping by for so
long surviving closure only by the skin
of their teeth Larry I made the risky
move into self-publishing during this
time they were also working on and
pursuing investment for two games dragon
commander and original sin divinity
original sin and dragon commander starts
that development alongside each other by
regional sin ended up being the game
that really propelled Celia into its new
era albeit still in an aura of
uncertainty and risk we don't want
somebody walking in here and telling us
what scrap the multiplayer and not
having anything to say about it right
and so to be able to do all of these
things we needed to go independent and
that's that's when I went and looked for
venture capitalists and so I managed to
convince them because I said look my
previous game sold that much I said oh
really so why aren't you rich I said
well there was broad and and so since
that was the right decision because
since then the story of Lehren has been
going upwards I mean there's obviously
there's been obstacles but essentially
it's always we overcame them and we came
better and better what we do - and
ultimately go bankrupt that's it for you
because everything is personal also
right so your March for the rest of your
life as somebody that failed so we don't
have this failing forward culture over
here and the risks that that I then had
to take were huge right so there were
moments where I couldn't I got stuck
with my car at the fuel station because
I couldn't pay the fuel anymore right
and we still had to make payroll to - -
and it was like literally every month
like how the hell are we gonna make
payroll this much right so just and keep
on working on it and still iterate over
what we were doing so it wasn't the
easiest thing in the world I mean and
but we went far for original sin I mean
we had the Kickstarter which was
fantastic that helped a lot but that
wasn't enough and then with the early
access that was also really good but
that wasn't enough so in the end we
didn't pay or v80 any more
and we've just to get extra time to work
on it because you could see that was in
the positive side you could see how good
this game was becoming right it just
needed time it just needed the
developers were working hard on it but
they they needed time right I mean and
you can't be creative if you can't make
mistakes so there's lots of mistakes
being made during develop development
then you have to come back from them you
know luckily for us I found one banker
who believed in it he said I said look I
said these are the amount of people that
are already playing in an early access
right we were close to 80 or 90 thousand
people and said that's a lot that's a
pre-order consider this a pre-order
right pre-orders go times 10 once your
release all right so you have to but you
have to believe in this and the bank
where we had their loan set well we
don't believe in this give us all the
money back this would have been the
intent so that guy actually gave me the
money that I needed to survive and that
gave us the opportunity to release the
game on June 30th which happened then to
be in the middle of the summer sale
which was earlier than it ever had been
on Steam and but I couldn't wait I
couldn't wait until July because if I
would have released it in July I
couldn't pay anything anymore and he
didn't sound June 30 we released
original sin and I KitKat had pulled it
all the way to the top of the summer
self capitalized navi from the fact that
so many people came to the summer sale
and like from one day or the other that
debts were over and so we could pay
later we could pay back the venture
capitalists we could buy them out so we
became masters of our own fate again the
Kickstarter for divinity original sin
raised just shy of 1 million dollars
after starting with a $400,000 goal and
likes when said it saw huge successes
when it released and was top of the
charts in a time where it could have
easily been lost under a sea of steam
sales but treats form for Larian
original sins launch was far from plain
sailing that moment in life I mean like
I had to I spent a long time recovering
from that period because not only that
we had problems with our translations
some of them caused by the fact that we
didn't have any cash and we had to make
commitments to distributors that it was
going to be translated on dev release it
wasn't we didn't have the German version
ready we didn't have French version
ready so the distributors are furious
with us right so we got all these like
threatening language from that side the
other hand he had that guy from the VA I
know I'm not giving you an extension
right I said come on man like normally
you do this
not here right that was it literally
they like or account installed and
normally you always get like three four
months grace periods so we said that's
what we need it so that's why we didn't
pay the v80 but this guy had decided no
I'm gonna come and collect and put you
on the blacklist a blacklist would have
meant the end of any any loan so we had
that going on all right so they were so
much things that need to be paid the
cost of goods needed to be paid or the
the the factory didn't want to deliver
it to the distributor switch was come to
mean even bigger fare and so while we
had plenty of debts at the congrats
Awards one big bet but I I was sure
because I'd seen people play it and seen
how fanatic they were about it so I said
this is gonna work right and so and
there was also this thing like we've had
it so many times in the past we had it
with divinity 1 we had it with a go to
Raccoonus we don't want to go to it
again the game gets released before it's
ready because it's at least to nowhere I
mean UK you you spent three years of
your life on making a game and then what
for because it's been released
prematurely and then it just lost all
the potential that was in there and
that's yeah so there so it needs
sometimes here you have to be lucky
awesome
now while luck may have well benefactor
Larian and the divinity series wouldn't
be where it's at today if their games
didn't deserve to be seen and played by
both their ravenous fans and newcomers
alike
while I've played games like divinity
too eager to CONUS it was the original
sin series that made me fall in love
with the world that Larry had created I
played it for a second time when the
enhanced edition came out and I fully
plan on revisiting river lon
when divinity original sin to definitive
edition releases and after spending some
time with swine and his team at the
Larian studio I got to see both the
passion and patience that has gone into
crafting these games they're a studio
that aren't afraid to admit their
mistakes or revisit what they've done
previously nor a studio that will sit on
their laurels or let projects lie when
they aren't 100% happy with them after
hearing the horror stories of how the
studio fought off bankruptcy
it's truly inspirational to see where
Larry nor at now a powerhouse of the C
RPG genre by asked if after all they'd
been through everything they'd learned
and the chances they took all the
feedback from Kickstarter if this was
finally the game that Larry wants to
make if divinity original sin 2 is the
game that's when had in mind in the
early day
is the lady the major the night and I'll
leave you with what he said this has
been an experiment and we are doing
certain things very well I think now
with the original Center there's a it's
a really good game it's a lot of fun to
play
which is where all the claim comes from
but there's a lot of things that we can
still do better and it will take time
because the studio has to grow also and
so the we need to need to grow a lot I
think so to be able to achieve what I
would like to achieve so yeah now
there's there's still there's still a
future for for what we're doing
you